da es dann ganz abgeschaltet werden darf
nicht mehr durch fließen und die
entschuldigung gaspipeline nord stream 1
natürlich 22 ist überhaupt nicht in
betrieb das kam hier gerade
durcheinander das ist aber eigentlich
ein ganz normaler vorgang also die
nord-stream-pipeline 1 ist diejenige
durch die im moment ungefähr noch 40
prozent der gasmenge fließt wir gehen
davon aus dass rund zehn tage nach der
erwartung das gas wieder angeschaltet
wird oder auch nicht denn was ist schon
normal in diesen tagen wie gesagt
normalerweise wird immer im sommer die
pipeline gewartet doch jetzt rätseln
alle ob wirklich wieder gas fließen wird
von russland nach deutschland wenn der
harn zu bleibt könnte hierzulande der
ernstfall ausgelöst werden und
möglicherweise müsste gas rationiert
werden so weit ist es noch nicht aber
die bundesregierung bereitet das
schlimmste vor und auch wenn das gas
nach der wartung wieder fließen sollte
wären damit längst nicht alle probleme
beseitigt denn die preise explodieren ja
jetzt schon darunter leiden verbraucher
und wirtschaft und der erste deutsche
gasversorger uni per ist bereits in
bedrängnis und hat staatshilfen
beantragt unser thema heute alarmstufe
gas sind wir auf den ernstfall
vorbereitet und das sind meine gäste
herzlich willkommen julia görges
wirtschaftskorrespondentin im
hauptstadtbüro der frankfurter
allgemeinen zeitung ich begrüße ganz
herzlich jakob schlandt er ist
redaktionsleiter background energie und
klima beim berliner tagesspiegel
willkommen auch gregor peter schmitz
vorsitzender der chefredaktion des
magazins stern und ich begrüße den
freien journalisten ulrich reitz ist
commune kolumnist bei focus online in
allen herzlich willkommen und noch ein
hinweis für sie liebe zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer sie können sich natürlich an
der diskussion beteiligen in den
sozialen medien wo unsere sendungen auch
gestreamt wird sie kennen die üblichen
wege ich habe es ja gerade schon gesagt
als zehnteilige wartung normalerweise
etwas ganz normales aber wir können alle
nicht hellsehen trotzdem vielleicht ein
kurzes schlaglicht von ihnen in der
runde kurze antwort frau löhr meinen sie
dass nach der wartung das gas wieder
fließt naja wenn es putin ums geld ginge
dann würde erst wieder fließen lasse
wenn ein gasfeld einmal eröffnet ist
dann kann man es nicht einfach wieder
schließen also wenn er das verkaufen
will dann müsste erst fließen lassen
wenn er demonstrieren will seine macht
gegenüber dem westen wenn er hier unruhe
schüren will dann wird er ist nicht
fließen lassen oder nur ein sehr
geringer menge und nach den erfahrungen
der letzten monate ist man davon
auszugehen dass er dieser fall eintritt
also sie glauben sowie soja putins
willkür irgendwie ich habe in einer sehr
geringer aber nicht auf dem üblichen
niveau diese gaspipelines waren entgegen
aller beteuerungen immer politische
projekte deswegen ist es auch jetzt eine
politische wertung keine rein technische
wartung der chef der bundesnetzagentur
hat man ja sehr klar auch selbst
formuliert und deswegen ist es
politische frage und damit eine offene
frage es kann durchaus passieren und der
deutsche industrie zumindest ist die
nervosität extrem groß dass das gas
nicht wieder anspringen ja genau über
das werden wir reden wenn es so kommt
oder so kommt herr reitz sie
husten aber
alkohol
sonst will ich bei ihm noch gar nicht
reingekommen
das ist eine waffe inland von putin also
warum sollte er sie nicht nutzen so und
was in zehn oder 14 tagen passiert ist
es ja offen ob es 10 14 tage sind und
die russen seien es kann auch länger
dauern daran sieht man ja schon sie
spielen mit unseren nerven und deswegen
würde ich denken die bundesregierung die
rechnet ja auch damit sowohl der
bundeskanzler wie auch der
bundeswirtschaftsminister dass putin
diese waffe nutzt
er stand ich würde sagen fifty fifty wir
kennen einfach die kalkulation im kreml
nicht wir wissen auch nicht genau wie
dringend benötigt russland im augenblick
devisen vermutlich eher nicht so
dringend und ich kann mir durchaus
vorstellen dass dieses
katz-und-maus-spiel noch weiter geht das
vielleicht ein bisschen noch
ausgeliefert wird dann wird nochmal
abgedreht mit einer fadenscheinigen
ausrede so wie wir es bei den
kompressorstationen es hat mir in der
tagesschau gerade gesehen schon erlebt
haben die jetzt wieder repariert und
zurückgeliefert werden sollen aber die
denken sie sich eben eine neue ausrede
aus fakt ist die
deutschen experten aus der gaswirtschaft
aber auch die politik sind zu der
eindeutigen einschätzung gekommen dass
diese reduktion auf 40 prozent technisch
nicht begründbar ist und insofern ist
das spiel des kremls ressort gespielt
wird das heißt das was wir gerade in der
tagesschau gesehen haben diese turbine
die sie auch gerade angesprochen haben
die soll jetzt also repariert aus kanada
dann jetzt nach deutschland geliefert
werden der kreml sprecher dimitri peskow
hat darauf schon reagiert hat gesagt ja
dann ist wenn wir die turbine kriegen
fahren wenn natürlich wieder hochbaum
ging das denn nicht gleich
so dass ich mich jetzt frage das hat ja
offensichtlich an der stätte
funktioniert könnte es dann
möglicherweise weitere forderungen geben
was russland noch braucht um wieder gas
fließen zu lassen aber da sind wir jetzt
im bereich der spekulation gucken wir
mal auf die aktuelle situation ob gas
wieder fließt oder nicht die gasspeicher
hierzulande sind im moment zu 63 prozent
ungefähr gefüllt wie lange könnte
deutschland denn die gasversorgung noch
sicherstellen jetzt ist sommer wir gehen
rein gab so wie beurteilen sie die
situation ja dass der kritische die
kritische phase wird tatsächlich der
herbst sein wenn die heizperiode wieder
beginnt erst im oktober
im moment ist es ja vor allem die
industrie die das gas braucht und klaus
müller der chef der netzagentur hatte
gesagt dass wenn die speicher zu 90
prozent am ersten november voll sind was
ja das ziel ist dass wir damit auch
nicht über den ganzen winter kämen
sondern zwei bis drei monate es reichen
würde bei den jetzigen stand ein bis
zwei monate also ist es klar bekennen
damit nicht über den winter und
spätestens im herbst musste die
bundesregierung dann entscheiden oder
die netzagentur in dem fall entscheiden
wer bekommt wie viel gas in welcher
reihenfolge wie verteilen wir dieses
knappe gut da gibt es ja jetzt schon
erste überlegungen also die
bundesregierung antizipiert ja jetzt
mögliche rationierung oder
vorrang der verbraucher bzw immer mehr
stimmen aus der industrie werden laut
aber wir brauchen auch dringend herr
schmitz wies ihre einschätzung also ich
bin ehrlich gesagt wenn ich auf die
bundesregierung schaut schon ein
bisschen überrascht wie gelassen man ist
ja olaf scholz sagte wenn er nach
energiespartipps gefragt wird robert
habeck redet relativ viel was wir uns
alles das alles an zumutung auf uns
zukommt aber so richtig ausformuliert
ist das noch nicht der
bundesfinanzminister ist mit seiner
hochzeit beschäftige sei ihm gegönnt
aber es sind schon sehr besondere zeiten
die da zu kommen gerade auf die
bundesrepublik wenn man in die industrie
hineinhorcht heißt es wirklich so ist
vielleicht die größte herausforderung
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg droht auch
bei corona der vorherigen krise hat die
kanzlerin irgendwann bei ihrem ja nicht
immer perfekten rhetorik in einen
krisenmodus geschaltet hat gesagt wir
müssen uns jetzt alle wirklich
zusammenreißen dieser herausforderung
stellen warum gibt es jetzt nicht diese
art von sparappellen beispielsweise an
die bevölkerung denn sie haben es
angesprochen jetzt müsste umgesteuert
werden weil wir uns vorbereiten auf
diese heitz phase im winter und es gibt
ja durchaus viele berechnungen die sagen
da ist erhebliches potenzial das wir
einsparen könnten bis zu 20 prozent um
unabhängiger zu werden denn wenn
wirklich eins muss man ganz klar sagen
wenn diese
gas zufuhr aus russland nicht wieder
hochgefahren wird dann werden wir all
das nicht mehr schaffen was wir bisher
geschafft haben wo wir die politik mit
sehr sehr viel geld muss man auch sagen
jetzt ein ausgleich geschaffen hat gas
flüssiggas gekauft hat norwegen
eingekauft dann überall sich angestrengt
hat aber das wird nicht reichen wenn
diese pleiten nicht wieder anspringen
ich finde den den punkt den sie gerade
gemacht haben die bundesregierung hat
eigentlich die erste phase verschlafen
kann man sagen auf der nachfrageseite
auf der angebotsseite hat man wie sie
gerade gesagt haben alles
zusammengekratzt was
dessen man so habhaft werden konnte
teilweise sogar kontraproduktiv
agiert was für mich der größte ärger
punkt ist eigentlich ein kleiner skandal
ist dass wir sogar eine 5 eine
subvention in höhe von 5 6 milliarden
euro für den gasverbrauch der industrie
jetzt auf den weg gebracht haben das
liegt gerade zum notifizierungsverfahren
in brüssel als die europäische
kommission muss noch ihren grünen
stempel drauf geben sie hat aber diesen
rahmen schon schaffen und 56 milliarden
um den gasverbrauch zu erhöhen das geht
nicht wir müssen jetzt die preise wirken
lassen
interessante frage übrigens diese
zweieinhalb monate die das reicht ja das
stimmt wenn man den alten gasverbrauch
mehr oder weniger fortschreibt das
preisniveau dass wir jetzt gerade an den
börsen haben ungefähr 180 euro pro
megawattstunde das ist etwa das
zehnfache dass der vorkrisenzeit in
corona was sogar noch viel niedriger das
frisst sich jetzt durch und das kommt
auch auf die verbraucher zu ich glaube
das ist auch ein großes thema für diese
sendung er dass die der der mir es ist
eine art prize tsunami der der kommt
gerade erst richtig in gang wir müssen
an allen ecken und enden sparen und wir
sind zu spät dran die bundesnetzagentur
wird erst im oktober die ergebnisse
vorliegen haben von einer betrachtung
zum beispiel wie wertschöpfungsketten
genau funktionieren und wie wir die
industrie möglichst effizient ohne
größeren schaden abschalten das was sie
gerade angesprochen haben was kommt auf
die verbraucher zu tatsächlich
beschäftigt dass viele zum beispiel mac
oder fragt auf twitter was kann
deutschland noch tun wenn es zum
gasstopp kommt millionen haushalte strom
und heizkosten nicht mehr bezahlen
können also geht jetzt erstmal darum gab
es also in erster linie nicht um strom
aber im normalen schumann fragt wie
lange reichen die speicher wenn man nur
privathaushalte und die lebensnotwendige
wirtschaft versorgen würde also die
frage wenn man jetzt schon rationieren
würde und thorsten landgraf fragt wie
bekommen wir den sozialen zusammenhalt
stabilisiert wenn die reichen die
vermögenden ihre fußbodenheizung mit 25
grad weiter heizen können und die mit
geringen einkommen aber die städtischen
wärme unterkünfte aufsuchen müssen die
jetzt eingerichtet werden sollen bereits
vor ähnlich fällt ihnen eigentlich auf
das bei den vier fragen die sie gerade
vorgelegt haben vorgelesen haben sich
keiner interessiert für die frage was in
der wirtschaft passiert also das größte
soziale problem haben wir
um lebensnotwendige wirtschaft hat einer
gefragt werden die radtour ist neben
lebensnotwendigen wirtschaft was die
lebensnotwendige wirtschaft ist es eine
interessante frage
wenn basf in die knie geht wenn energie
und intensive betriebe in die knie gehen
wie beispielsweise aluminium industrie
in ostwestfalen die stahlindustrie und
so weiter dann reden wir von einem
arbeitslosen problemlos sich gewaschen
hat und das wird das größte soziale
probleme wir werden dazu führen wir
haben geredet herr schmidt hat es
gemacht über eine sogenannte gas triage
also über die frage wer kriegt das zeug
wenn es knapp wird das würden
diskussionen vor der herr scholz und
herr habeck unheimlich angst haben weil
sie diesen sozialen zusammenhalt
wahnsinnig gefährdet und über die frage
der ausgleichsmaßnahmen für die armen
schlucker die dann nicht mehr bezahlen
können soll ja wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe die konzertierte aktion
befinden das heißt das findet auch dann
erst im herbst statt da gibt es jetzt
schon verschiedene
vorschläge für aber das findet erst dann
schalt ich finde man muss sich darauf
konzentrieren was passiert eigentlich
wenn die wirtschaft in die knie geht und
zehntausende von arbeitsplätzen wenn
nicht mehr zur debatte stehen das
kriegen sie nicht mehr aufgefangen mit
instrumenten wie kurzarbeit die wir in
der pandemie
eingeführt haben und die wirklich
wunderbar
funktioniert haben deswegen ist die
nervosität groß und es ist kein zufall
dass etwa in der faz
der basf-chef seit monaten
davor warnt dass ein komplettes
unternehmen mit über 100 1000
beschäftigten eben in die knie geht die
folge kann sondern dass die basf um
dabei mal zu bleiben ist einfach der
größte ist der größte chemie unter dem
was von deutschland haben tester sagte
verabschiedeten los deutschland solche
diskussionen werden sie haben letzter
satz fällt ihnen eigentlich auf dass wir
immer mehr eine whatever it takes
rhetorik haben das heißt also die
rhetorik der finanzkrise aus 2008
folgende die kehrt gerade
mit massiver wucht zu stimmt also sie
kehrt zurück nur halte ich die aktuelle
herausforderung für noch größer weise
wir hatten jetzt eine krise in der
finanzkrise wir hatten eine cola krise
ist es kaum zu glauben dass er
mittlerweile darüber reden dass selbst
die korona krise im vergleich fast nur
wir waren unter anderen umständen aktiv
weil damals ist im staat
glücklicherweise noch so gut ging das
wirklich vieles abgefedert werden konnte
jetzt hat sich diese schon rasant
geändert alleine der zinsaufwand in
christian lindner im moment treiben muss
wegen der gestiegenen gestiegenen zinsen
für unsere schulden ist so viel höher
als beispielsweise während der
finanzkrise und auch während der korona
krise das ist ein riesiges problem auf
uns zukommen ich halte das für das
wirklich den größtmöglichen
verteilungskampf es gibt und deswegen in
der tat haben habeck und scholz davor
panische angst viele haben den auftritt
von robert habeck gesehen also nur der
alten bundesregierung vor hielt was
alles falsch gemacht worden damit hat er
vollkommen recht
er hätte doch noch schärfer formulieren
können nur vieler wähler denken ja immer
an diesen schönen satz von einstein mich
interessiert die zukunft der gedenke ich
zu leben es hilft dir als politiker
einfach nichts zurück zu greifen und du
wirst jetzt in verantwortung genommen
und davor hat diese koalition da wo es
richtig dass es das zurückblicken jetzt
in der akuten krise nichts hilft aber
weil sie die note und angesprochen
hatten wir ihn sowieso schon vorbereitet
ist eine lange liste von vorwürfen an
die vorgängerregierung die robert habeck
am donnerstag im bundestag formuliert
hatten wir mal rein immer größere
abhängigkeit von russischen fossilen
energien mangelnden diversifizierung
nichteinhaltung der klimapolitischen
ziele schleppen naja zusammengebrochener
ausbau der
energien zerstörung der solar und in
weiten teilen auch der windindustrie die
wir hier in diesem ganz schön hatten
verlust von zukunftsfähigen
arbeitsplätzen und einem
marktwirtschaftlichen hochlauf für die
zukunft technologien bremsen in europa
kein plan kein überblick aber sagen das
was wir jetzt machen ist
schönwetterpolitik sehr geehrte damen
und herren buchstäblich steht
deutschland im regen hätten wir diese
pakete vor zehn jahren durchgezogen wir
würden ganz anders heute darf ja das war
vor allem kritik an der vorgänger
kanzlerin angela merkel die
unionsgeführte regierung und spüre ich
sagen muss das ist spd-koalitionspartner
war ich wollte das nicht unterschlagen
an der stelle das war eine lange liste
und wir haben ja gerade beschrieben
welches szenario möglicherweise drohen
könnte was wirtschaftsrezession angeht
kein vergleich zu corona und corona war
schon sehr schlimm whatever it takes
wir wollen alles ausgeben um das
schlimmste zu verhindern lassen sie es
uns mal ab schichten was jetzt schon
beschlossen wurde vielleicht fange ich
mit ihnen an frauen ist ja dass man
jetzt um die energieversorgung überhaupt
mal zu sichern die kohlekraftwerke
verlängert hat zu sagen okay also wir
müssen davon wegkommen dass durch gas
strom hergestellt wird da schon mal gas
sparen wir lassen die kohle länger
laufen das natürlich auch gerade für die
grünen bitter
das ist aber die maßnahme die
beschlossen wurde inwiefern hilft die
jetzt und was muss noch geschehen in
anbetracht des szenarios das hilft
natürlich weil man dann mehr
kohlekraftwerke zur stromerzeugung
heranziehen kann und dann gas ein
speichern kann oder eben für andere
zwecke für die industrie für die
privatverbraucher nutzen kann aber
natürlich ist dieses die sind in dieser
ganzen gesetzespakete jetzt die diese
woche auf den weg gebracht wurden die
lösen ja das problem nicht das problem
ist das gas ist knapp und es wird es
mutmaßlich noch für längere zeit bleiben
das heißt sie verhindern nur dass wir
quasi oder versuchen den effekt etwas
abzumildern
aber sie lesen unser problem nicht was
die entlastungen angeht gab es jetzt
schon zwei und leistungspakete die
eeg-umlage ist jetzt anfang juli
weggefallen ist wird im september die
energiepreis pauschale für die
privatverbraucher geben also da ist
durchaus einiges auf den weg gebracht
aber nach allem was wir an den zahlen
sehen wird das nicht ausreichen vor
allem nicht wenn die preise weiter
steigen um tatsächlich die die
zusatzkosten in die die einzelnen haben
werden zu ersetzen und das ist weil sie
das eben ansprachen mit den vorherigen
krisen denke ich auch so ein bisschen
das problem der haben in der korona
krise sind altmaier und scholz
angetreten mit der bazooka und dem
versprechen mehr oder weniger jeder
sollte einen status quo halten und es
wird niemandem was schlimmes passieren
und ich stimme ihnen völlig zu diese
krise jetzt ist eine völlig andere von
der dimension her wenn das gas knapp
bleibt das ist ja die prämisse und wir
müssen jetzt tatsächlich sparen also es
muss überall muss der verbrauch runter
gehen und das betrifft sowohl die
privaten als auch die industrie und ob
diese herausforderung die darf vor und
steht bei allen schon so richtig
angekommen ist da habe ich meine zweifel
dass ich ganz kurzer ergänzung über die
verschiedenen krisen gesprochen haben
der unterschied ist ja diesmal auch koma
war eine globale krise die
weltfinanzkrise in gewisser hinsicht
auch jetzt haben wir aber weil sie die
industrie angesprochen haben natürlich
welt regionen wie asien amerika die
ähnliche probleme nicht haben ja also
ich die nicht ein ähnliches
energieproblem gerade haben wie
deutschland das sich besonders abhängig
gemacht hat das macht es natürlich auch
noch schwieriger und völlig richtig dass
über sparen haben wir schon häufiger
gesprochen da finde ich fehlt es an
diesem modell tx ansatz bei es gibt ja
auch vorschläge von verhaltensökonomen
und ähnlichen die sagen wir müssen zum
beispiel anreizsysteme prämien einführen
jetzt im sommer damit es sich auch
auswirkt winter weil die leute auch ein
robert habe glaube ich immer davon
ausgehen die menschen machen es ohnehin
und sie sind vernünftig und sie denken
daran wenn die preise steigen so sind
die menschen aber nicht wissen die
bürger dorthin bewegen und das hat in
deutschland verschiedenen phasen auch
schon gut funktioniert und warum darüber
nicht geredet wird übrigens auch an die
industrie auch da gibt es ja modelle die
man aktionsmodelle zum sparen und so
weiter einführen könnte die liegen in
den ministerien herum es wird aber nicht
drüber geredet
ist nicht alter
sparen komme ich gleich genau da hatte
er habe gesagt ist nicht alt das ist
unappetitlich wenn man dafür geld
fordert dass man sich und sparen.de
mitarbeiter aktiv
ja ich komme gleich zum sparen weil das
ist ja eine komponente die andere
komponente ist was können wir auffangen
wir haben es gerade mit der kohle
beschrieben wo können wir weniger gas
zur stromerzeugung einsetzen und eine
frage die bei uns auf twitter debattiert
wird ist natürlich die frage der
verlängerung der atomkraftwerke
jonathan packhof gefragt was wäre der
vorteil von akw es im streck betrieb
bleibt die menge an produziertem
atomstrom nicht gleich nur anders über
die monate verteilt ich gebe diese frage
mal in die runde und anker welter fragt
könnte man tatsächlich die gasknappheit
mit den laufenden drei akw ausgleichen
wenn es am wenn sie am netz blieben
hierzu gibt es ja viele widersprüchliche
aussagen und ich glaube auch hier in der
runde ist die haltung zu der frage
durchaus unterschiedlich von der fang
ich mal mit ihnen an das land ja was
nicht noch die idee mit den maklern
sozusagen klassische atomkraftgegner
tschernobyl
aber ich muss sagen die klimadebatte und
die prioritäten niemand da setzt haben
da meiner meinung schon etwas geändert
und ich glaube in dieser situation wäre
es einfach ein extrem wichtiges signal
ja es sind nur fünf prozent der
deutschen stromerzeugung ja das gas dass
man damit einsparen kann ist die
gasmengen ist noch mal geringer weil die
kernkraftwerke nicht immer dann zum
einsatz kommen kommen können wenn die
gaskraftwerke laufen die laufen ja nur
einige stunden pro tag wenn besonders
viel strom verbraucht wird also noch ein
abschlag trotzdem worüber reden wir denn
hier wir reden über belastungen für die
bürger die
fast schon unvorstellbar sind und auch
unbezahlbar sind die reden wirklich von
härtesten sparmaßnahmen die uns drohen
und dieser strikt betrieb wäre aus
meiner sicht ein sehr sehr guter
kompromiss weil man sagt damit ja nicht
die laufzeitverlängerung ist gekippt
jetzt wieder neue akw bauen sondern man
sagt man lässt die brennstäbe drin um
zur frage von herrn packhof gerade zu
kommen man lässt die brennstäbe
sozusagen im betrieb ausflügen über den
31.12 2022 hinaus die produzieren noch
sehr viel wärme die leistung nimmt nimmt
dann ab ob man braucht also auch keine
neuen brennstäben man kann eigentlich
diese debatte über das einkaufen von
brennstäben was er angeblich so
schwierig ist
über diesen wirklich sehr schwierigen
winter hinaus aufschieben und dass sich
die grünen da sperrung verstehe ich
nicht genau so wie ich nicht verstehe
dass die fdp beim thema tempolimit
sperrt und ich finde es wird zeit dass
die bundesregierung auch zeigt dass sie
über ihren schatten springt die
einzelnen parteien bereit sind über
ihren schatten zu springen um diese
krise zu lösen und das wäre zum beispiel
ein deal den ich mir da vorstellen
könnte das kann nicht sein dass wir hier
über belastungen von 5 6000 euro die auf
gas haushalte die welt deutschland wird
fallen in gas und in nicht gas aushalte
wer mit gas heizt wird mit unglaublichen
mehrkosten pro
haushalt
leben
vielschichtiges thema wie man merkt sie
haben jetzt gerade gut erklärt also die
die die brennstäbe sollen ausklingen es
muss kein neues uran aus russland
gekauft werden also noch mal kurz ich
fand interessant ihre genese auch wie
sie sich persönlich entwickelt haben in
der betrachtung darauf es wird ja
manchmal im rückblick so getan als ob
damals angela merkel eigenhändig
atomkraftwerke abgeschaltet es war
natürlich eine politische entscheidung
damals die noch nicht beeinflusst war
von der krawatte in ähnlicher form heute
und ich habe heute morgen amüsiert ein
interview mit markus söder im
bayerischen ministerpräsidenten gelesen
in dem er auch wieder sagt jetzt muss
endlich über atomkraft gerät werden er
hat natürlich damals auch begeistert
geworben als damaliger umweltminister
noch und gesagt wir müssen auf jeden
fall aussteigen das muss man glaube ich
schon im hinterkopf behalten trotzdem
ist es natürlich eine entscheidung die
man heute in dem sich der sichtweise
überdenken könnte trotzdem muss man
natürlich auch zugeben die akute krise
werden wir damit nicht lösen man kann
sagen es ist ein kleines puzzle ist ein
sehr teures puzzle übrigens auch der
stapel das letztlich übernehmen müssen
weil du wirst keinen privaten betreiber
finden der dieses risiko auf sich nimmt
die sind ja sehr zurückhaltend in dieser
debatte ist kann man einspeisen es ist
aber wirklich nur ein weiteres puzzle
von vielen puzzlestein die sie ja auch
aufgeführt haben tempolimit ähnliches wo
man sagen muss ich finde man muss den
kunden schon zugutehalten sie haben sich
schon sehr bewegt in dieser debatte
allein beim thema kohle aber das ist
etwas wo sie wahrscheinlich
können sie kurz ausführen was sie gerade
meinen mit warum wird sich da kein
privater betreiber finden warum es das
risiko so groß dass das habe ich nicht
verstanden weil die haftungsrisiken
einfach so riesig sind wir haben ja
atomkraft ist überall weltweit ein sehr
teures geschäft auch in den ländern die
sich dafür noch entschieden haben es ist
wenn dann eine staatlich übernommenen
aufgabe das du bestimmte haftungen und
so weiter über nimmst dann kann es
funktionieren aber die
privatwirtschaftlichen einem jahr
wollten ja auch alle raus da also die
die möchten da nicht mehr einsteigen man
könnte sagen als staat ja wir machen das
wieder und wir strecken ist wie sie wie
sie ausgeführt haben nur wie gesagt ich
glaube eine generelle rückkehr zur
atomkraft das sagt ja auch selbst markus
wird also der 1
zwei punkte sind enorm wichtig und sie
haben damit angefangen
kommunikation wenn alle betroffen sind
kann ich den einzelnen gruppen
rausnehmen oder nicht sondern muss ich
sagen ich muss alles machen also was
jetzt geht muss ich alles machen es sei
denn jemand bringt ein argument vor das
darf sie auf keinen fall machen wenn
nicht diese methode anwendet ist die
atomkraft drin so oder sind alte
vorhalte einfach nicht mehr angebracht
weil sie auf anderen feldern auch nicht
lassen und das zweite ist
krisenkommunikation es ist schon
bemerkenswert dieser unterschied
zwischen olaf scholz in der
kommunikation und robert habeck robert
habe jedes interview
gesagt wäre es furchtbar es wird schlimm
usw und olaf scholz tonlage ist eine
andere er war zwar vor sozialen kosten
aber er sagt letztendlich da wo ich bin
ist alles okay das ist eine andere
krisenkommunikation und ich sind
deswegen den hinweis dass eine gesamte
bundesregierung also alle drei
betroffenen parteien wo jeder seine
interessen hat jede partei hat ihre
interessen da kann man als bürger schon
erwarten dass die sich auf eine
kommunikation einigen die dem ernst der
lage bewusst wir machen ja alle einig
dass diese krise außerordentlich ist so
und da kann man schon erwarten dass
jeder seiner seine persönlichen oder
seine partei punkte für diesen moment
mal nach hinten stellen können sagt wir
machen alles was nötig kann ändern
vorgeben muss
bereits dann die frage an sie und die
fdp muss kein tempolimit mitgehen das
tempolimit
die lage ist so ernst dass jeder über
seinen schatten springen muss müsste die
fdp über das tempolimit sicher wenn die
atomkraft ein symbolthema ist weil die
margen nicht so groß sind die das jetzt
in der gaskrise uns helfen wird ein
tempolimit ist das ein vergleichbares
setting das heißt also die marge ist
auch da vergleichsweise gering nur ist
es jetzt ein thema von glaubwürdigkeit
und deswegen muss man diese dinge
einfach tun aber ich würde widersprechen
dass atomkraft nur ein symbolthema ist
also wenn man ja richtig aber wenn man
sich mal zurück erinnert an die zeit der
ölkrise mitte der 70er jahre da hat mir
eine ähnliche situation
deutschland war total abhängig von öl
die wirtschaft und die privatverbraucher
und wir haben das gründen den größten
anteil aus den arabischen ländern
bezogen dann war es auf einmal nicht
mehr da und das begann eine große
debatte darüber um himmels willen wie
sichern wir jetzt unsere
energieversorgung damals die gleichen
debatten wie heute wir fangen die
temperaturen in öffentlichen gebäuden
runter das war alles schon mal da und
danach begann eine debatte wir müssen
uns breiter in unserem energiemix
aufstellen wir können nicht mehr so
einseitig auf diesen einen energieträger
setzen auf das öl dann wurden
reihenweise die atomkraftwerke geplant
das waren die gründer stunde der grünen
also das ist alles in dieser zeit
entstanden ist man auf einmal
ölbohrungen in der nordsee unternommen
also es war klar wir müssen uns breiter
aufstellen und was mir tatsächlich sorge
bereitet ist unser großer fokus darauf
dass wir jetzt alles mit strom machen
werden in zukunft die elektroautos die
heizungen wärmepumpen die industrie den
wasserstoff da braucht man auch große
mengen strom dafür alles strom und alles
aus erneuerbaren energien wo wir ja alle
wissen das ist der ausbau hin meilenweit
zurück also ich würde mir jetzt
tatsächlich im sinne von jeder muss aber
seinen schatten springen eine offene
debatte darüber wünschen mit welchem
energiemix wir in die zukunft gehen
wollen und da finde ich das jetzt auch
über einen streik betrieb hinaus man
darüber reden sollte ob die atomkraft
einer dieser elemente ist genau weil das
ist jetzt der unterschied damit wir den
zuschauer und die zuschauerin hier an
der stelle mitnehmen also der streck
betrieb wäre jetzt wirklich nur das uran
was da ist glüht ausführen wird auch
immer kälter und so nah er hat nicht
mehr so viel leistung und neue sagen
genau also ist nicht eigentlich mit den
herausforderungen und der der der
elektrizität in zukunft benötigt wird
sehen konnte ist es nicht richtig sogar
neues uran zu kaufen und wieder richtig
ich will auch nicht sagen dass das jetzt
die lösung ist aber ich finde wir müssen
darüber diskutieren und das was habeck
und lemke im frühjahr gemacht haben als
das thema ja schon mal kurz hoch packte
dann an wir haben das geprüft und das
geht nicht und dann stellte sich heraus
nahm aber mit denjenigen die das sagen
könnten also mit dem atomunternehmen sie
jetzt nicht so wirklich gesprochen das
ging mir zu schnell also ich finde wir
müssen offen als gesellschaft darüber
diskutieren was wollen wir wie wichtig
uns der klimaschutz wie wichtig ist uns
energiesicherheit und ich würde schon
dafür plädieren dass wir einen mix
brauchen und uns nicht wieder einseitig
wir können nun nicht sozusagen eine drei
jahre die die grundrechte nein das ist
richtig denn wenn sie sich in
industrialisierten zonen aufhalten in
deutschland dann dann sagen ihnen die
unternehmen also passt man auch dass mit
der energiewende buch schwierige
geschichte aber jetzt haben wir uns
darauf eingestellt die ganzen prozesse
strom verwendung und wie wir überhaupt
das alles aufstellen haben wir jetzt
umsortiert deswegen haben sie eine
energie industrie in eine gespaltene
meinungen die hälfte sagt können wir uns
vorstellen mit atom die andere hälfte
sei wolle man nichts für uns gibt im
moment unternehmungen und heilfroh dass
wir noch ihren alten ölkessel haben und
den jetzt reaktivieren um gas zu stimmen
ja vielleicht sogar die deutsche
energiepolitik liegt absolut in trümmern
und gerade deswegen finde ich es
schwierig dass so wenig oder dass die
regierung so darauf fokussiert ist die
folgen möglichst abzumildern verstehe
ich völlig aus politischer sicht das
würde ich an der stelle wahrscheinlich
sehr ähnlich machen aber eigentlich muss
die breite öffentlichkeit begreifen wie
ernst und dramatisch die lage ist und
das muss auch von dieser regierung
kommuniziert werden dass wir wirklich
dort komplett umdenken müssen also
eigentlich auch die preise haben sich am
anfang angesprochen streng genommen ist
zum anderen die höhe schießen lassen wir
sind ja schon die höhe geschossen und
weiter in die höhe schießen lassen um
klar zu machen es geht so nicht weiter
dass hier muss man muss an vielen
stellen ausgleich natürlich bei sozial
schwachen und ähnlichen nur eigentlich
müssen wir sagen wir müssen wirklich
komplett neu gedeckt heißt krabat nicht
noch mal nen euro nl gb dass die
subvention oder den gasverbrauch die
fünf bis sechs milliarden sofort
streichen dass er wirklich das absolute
minimum so genau ok jetzt jetzt
versuchen die kurse also
für für unser publikum
so richtig es ist es ja ein thema wo
alles mit allem zusammenhängt wir haben
gerade das aktive aufgemacht muss man
jetzt nicht ehrlich darüber reden dass
atomkraft wirklich ein teil unseres
energiemixes ist und dann müsste man
auch mehr als streck betrieb sondern
richtig wieder darin investieren das ist
jetzt aber strom wieder jetzt kommen wir
da sind wir ja gestartet und sie haben
gerade völlig zu recht gesagt im moment
ist der deutsche staat dabei das
schlimmste abzufedern völlig
verständlich völlig richtig aber damit
natürlich auch in gewisser weise die
steuerungsmöglichkeit nimmt denn wenn es
nicht wirklich schmerzt und teurer wird
dann muss man ja auch nicht umsteuern
jetzt haben sie gesagt jetzt bin ich bei
den unterstützung nicht nur
privathaushalte sondern für die
industrieunternehmen die mitgas arbeiten
die jetzt schon subventionen kriegen
sagen sie das muss sofort auf ja das
muss sofort aufhören ein paar anfragen
gestellt diesen mehr oder weniger
versandet antwortet worden ich glaube da
wird schon gebracht und das zu streichen
schon lange nicht mehr in der
kommunikation aufgetaucht welche
maßnahmen geht es da konkret da geht es
um einen betriebskostenzuschuss für
gasverbrauch insgesamt 5 6 milliarden
euro wie gesagt derjenige der den
gasverbrauch und vielleicht gas
verbraucht und dafür mehr als doppelt so
viel wie vorher zahlt was auf jeden fall
erfüllt ist der bekommt dann einen teil
vom staat ersetzt dieser mehrkosten ist
bedeutet im endeffekt im ökonomischen
anreiz in der betriebsführung bedeutet
das einen anreiz mehr gas zu verbrauchen
da brauchen wir überhaupt nicht drüber
diskutieren auch wenn herr lindner und
her fällt sein berater und so weiter da
irgendwie versuchen das möglichst klein
zu reden das ist quatsch
würde insofern widersprechen als dass
man das natürlich hinterfragen kann aber
die regierung in diesem fall schon
deutlich klüger vorgegangen ist als
während der korona pandemie also dieser
zuschuss der viele unternehmen im
gespräch es soll ja auch nur dann
greifen wenn die energierechnung schon
mehr als doppelt so hoch ist wie im
vorjahr und nur dieser anteil würde dann
anteilig zuschuss also dass da sind
schon deutlich höhere hürden eingezogen
und wenn man das vergleicht in der
korona zeit sind über 70 milliarden euro
an zuschüssen an die unternehmen
geflossen jetzt reden wir über fünf bis
sechs also ich finde da ist schon wurde
schon durchaus maß gehalten und wir
müssen halt immer auch noch darauf
achten dass die industrie uns erhalten
bleibt und eben nicht in andere länder
stichwort amerika wo der gaspreis viel
günstiger aber dann situation ihre ich
doch nicht den gasverbrauch dann
stabilisiere ich die anders ja sie
sparen mit wahnsinnigen schmerzen im
augenblick jede kilowattstunde ein und
wollen das auch den bürgern erklären da
kann ich da keine anreize zu setzen also
nochmal zu den und übrigens dieses
prinzip müssen wir durchziehen wir
müssen auch bei den signalen an die
bürger ich finde zum beispiel den csu
vorschlag gar nicht so schlecht zu sagen
es gibt einen grund gas deputat
beispielsweise die hälfte des vorjahres
verbrauchs und das bekomme ich stark
subventioniert das kein problem weil die
kilowattstunde die ich jetzt ein paare
die kostet mich ja ganz ganz viel die
rede
privathaushalte aber in der industrie
kann man es eigentlich genauso machen
der größte fehler wäre es jetzt zu sagen
die ökonomen sagen die marginale
kilowattstunde also die kilowattstunde
die ich jetzt verbrauchen oder einsparen
kann die oben drauf die muss super teuer
sein und dann kann ich unten schon geld
reinschieben auch soziale
stützungsmaßnahmen und weise das ist
hälfte des verbrauchs jetzt sei es
privat haushalt sei es industrielle
pension irrt auf einem akzeptablen preis
und alles was darüber hinaus geht
genauso das plädiert damit man eben auch
die steuerungswirkung hat damit meinen
ganz starken sparanreiz hat es muss sich
sie müssen sich denken die klebebänder
die ich kaufe um die fenster hier dicht
zu machen die müssen ihnen einen hut
bringen über den winter
wollte ihren gedankengang folgen der ja
dann doch
stark verkürzte es an der stelle aber
okay dass das wäre nicht altern ist
etwas anderes
aber ich möchte auch gerne nochmal
unsere nutzerinnen und nutzer mit
reinbringen also wieder das thema
gasstopp gas mangel bruno frieden berg
ratner fragt im gästebuch können wir
nicht über die niederlande und norwegen
mehr gas lieferungen an fordern eine
frage ich glaube sie hatten schon
angedeutet also auf der angebotsseite
hat man versucht alles einzukaufen was
möglich ist hans gnant fragt wie
schätzen sie das ein sind
handwerksbetriebe und deutsche
heizungshersteller auf eine schnelle
umstellung auf wärme punkten vorbereitet
das wäre ja jetzt so die alternative
mehr frauen ein es gab schon zu beginn
des jahres berechnungen dass in die
65.000 installateure fielen um das zu
machen und die ziele deutschland das ja
immer ganz gut wenn ziele auf papier zu
schreiben so auch habeck 6 millionen
wärmepumpen die er bis 2030 erreichen
will aber es fehlen schlichtweg zum
einen die geräte wegen der nach wie vor
gesperrten lieferketten aber es fehlen
eben auch die handwerker die die
installieren und auch jetzt
moment die politiker die zum
hydraulischen abgleich bei der der
heizungsanlage raten ich meine wer mal
versucht hat gerade einen handwerker so
einen hydraulischen abgleich zu bekommen
weiß da kann man dann auch gut ein paar
monate warten müssen aber das ist also
sehr interessant weil das hatte ich mich
nämlich auch schon gefragt mit dem papa
ich okay also das geht jetzt so schnell
auch nicht wenn sie die beziehungen zu
ihrem handwerker haben vielleicht schon
aber es gibt also man muss halt durchaus
gerade sehr lange auf termine warten und
es gibt ja auch noch andere dinge weder
die kaputt gehen oder was gepflegt
werden muss also weil wir das thema mit
wie können wir alle dazu beitragen wie
können wir alle sparen ja schon mehrfach
an gerissen haben und sie bereits auch
ein habeck zitiert haben an der stelle
ist nicht alter was also jetzt in diesem
sinne herrn habeck zitiert haben was
sehen sie denn also wie müssten
bürgerinnen und bürger reagieren was
muss jetzt getan werden was haben sie
vielleicht auch für persönliche tipps
für den einzelnen wie können wir helfen
oder müssen wir dafür finanziellen
anreiz vom staat kriegen finanzieller
anreize können uns gar nicht mehr
leisten die müssen ja bezahlt werden
der staat hat kein geld er habe kein
geld herr scholz hat kein geld der
lindner halt kein geld sondern sie
verwalten unser geld so das heißt also
das was stattfindet ist eh nur eine
umverteilung zahlen tut am ende sowieso
immer nur einer nämlich der bürger das
mal vorneweg ich lese
dass gemeinden sparen schwimmbäder
werden heruntergefahren die
straßenbeleuchtung wird heruntergefahren
und so weiter ist der diskutiert in
berlin sagen sie jetzt um gottes willen
des brandenburger tors beleuchtet
bleiben da kann man anderer meinung sein
mehr alle sparen dann finde ich dann da
muss es auch überall haben wir eben
darüber geredet kommunikation und
glaubwürdigkeit dann muss das auch
überall stattfinden zu denjenigen dingen
und die für mich dazu gehören ist wir
haben seit 2017 das war drei jahre nach
dem ersten einmarsch von putin in der
ukraine
wir haben seit 2017 fracking verbot wir
könnten uns auch gedanken machen über
die frage so wie früher
gesagt hat dass wir uns grundsätzlich
gedanken machen über die atomkraft
könnten wir uns auch gedanken machen
über fracking es gibt zwei abteilungen
dabei ist eines das konventionelle das
andere das unkonventionelle fracking
konventionelles flecken machen wir seit
50 jahren ich lerne da bin ich kein
experte ich kann es mir nur anlesen auch
aus gutachten ich lerne wir haben
vorhaben oder vorkommen in deutschland
die uns ein bis zwei jahre im
konventionellen fracking das was wir
seit langem machen über wasser halten im
unkonventionellen fracking tiefer
schwerer mehr chemie
erreicht im boden gewinnen genau reicht
es für 30 jahre und ich finde wenn man
über alles nachdenkt auch das ist nicht
eine sache die uns morgen früh hilft
aber entschuldigung herr scholz hat
gesagt wir müssen uns darauf einstellen
ein bis zwei jahre das sagt auch die
emotionen also müssen wir doch er hat es
doch keinen sinn nur am morgen früh zu
denken sondern müssen auch daran denken
wie kommen wir durch den winter und wie
kommen wir ins frühjahr und da kommt
möglicherweise ja noch ein winter
so ein bisschen putzig klingt das
einzelne gemeinden ihren brunnen nicht
mehr
beheizen oder oder laufen lassen oder
oder die lichter abschalten also es
kommt es potenziell kommt eine
wesentlich dramatische situation auf uns
zu wenn nämlich wirklich klaus müller
irgendwann und nichts gegen klaus müller
ein sehr ehrenwerter beamte aber
trotzdem wenn er irgendwann mit der
bundesnetzagentur entscheiden muss wer
in der deutschen industrie gas zugeteilt
bekommen wer nicht das ist eine
situation die wir in deutschland noch
nie erlebt haben und die wird ein gern
auch mal ganz andere verwerfungen
auslösen und auch eine ganz andere
diskussion noch einmal nach deutschland
tragen also das muss uns klar sein und
das ist auch das wovor die regierung am
meisten angst wovor übrigens auch die
bundesnetzagentur am meisten angst hat
weil sie diese entscheidung natürlich
gar nicht treffen möchte dann ist
wahrscheinlich die schwerste
entscheidung seit dem zweiten band die
man treffen muss
pauli ich würde da auch das unterstützen
wollen weil seit beginn dieser krise
oder seit beginn der sanktionen ist ja
immer das mantra der regierung gewesen
die sanktionen und das was russland dann
im gegenzug macht schadet russland mehr
als das uns schadet und ich denke und
wenn das dann im herbst also wenn es
dann der ganze fall eintritt und hier
halt wirklich gas rationiert wird und
die erst städte irgendwelche wärme
zelthallen eröffnen dann wird das schon
sehr schwer für die regierung sein zu
erklären dass dieses mantra noch gilt
und dann wird auch die diskussion ob das
alles so richtig ist was wir hier machen
die wird dann nochmal auf kommen also
aus als putin
am freitag also vor zwei tagen genau mit
diesem szenario gedroht und jetzt
stellen sie sich mal einen moment vor
ohne airbag hat sich mit dieser frage
schon beschäftigt stellen sie mal vor in
zwei wochen sagt die bundesregierung
gesagt russland okay
moskau zwei oder ihr könnt wieder gas
kriegen
können wieder gas kriegen aber nur wenn
ihr noch stream zeigt macht was machen
wir dann das heißt also wir putin sitzt
in vielfacher hinsicht einen viel
längeren hebel als wir uns das im moment
klar machen die haben noch mal klicken
ins wespennest gestochen so zu sagen wir
sind aber am ende der sendezeit dieses
presseclubs im ersten andere angelangt
wir sehen wie vielschichtig und wie
intensiv das thema noch weiter
diskutiert werden könnte bis hierhin
vielen dank für ihr interesse im ersten
folgt jetzt weiter das europamagazin mit
bericht aus brüssel aber wenn sie an
diesem thema dran bleiben wollen dann
können sie das tun auf phoenix und wdr 5
presseclub nachgefragt vielen dank für
ihr interesse
[Musik]
und wir sind wieder drauf und zwar bei
phoenix und wdr 5 pressegruppe
nachgefragt zu unserem thema heute
alarmstufe gas sind wir auf den
ernstfall vorbereitet und jetzt haben
unsere hörerinnen und hörer zeit uns
fragen zu stellen in dieser runde direkt
und ich beginne mit horst schorle aus
wolsfeld guten tag und was möchten sie
von der runde wissen bitte ja einen
schönen
sonntagnachmittag in die runde und meine
frage wäre folgende ich hatte in der
washington post gelesen dass die usa die
düngemittel die sie einführen von
russland nicht sanktioniert sondern im
gegenteil in den letzten monaten fast 20
prozent mehr eingeführt hat ganz zu
schweigen von frankreich die das uran
aus russland für ihre atomkraftwerke
nicht auf der sanktionsliste hat warum
machen wir als deutschland wo wir doch
hören auch sie haben das diskutiert
der knapp ist dass unsere industrie
schwer treffen kann die haushalte
treffen dann warum nehmen wir ein so
knappes gut bei uns auf die
sanktionsliste wo es die anderen nicht
machen und da ich mit einem freund von
herrn söder bin
würde ich gerne von ihm die antwort ja
wohlfeld ich glaube eine
entschuldigung
jetzt haben sie mich völlig
durcheinandergebracht er ist wird
wahrscheinlich erst mal auf seine
freundschaft zu herrn söder reagieren
und da
ja ich nehme interessiert zur kenntnis
schon freundschaftlich verortet werde
ich habe ich nur zitiert und das
amüsiert beobachtet wie er eine wendung
hingelegt was ist schon mal vorgekommen
ist in seiner karriere aber zur frage
auf ihre antwort weil ich auch gerne an
die experten ist ein weiterspielen würde
weil er natürlich noch weit kompetenter
darin dahin ist dass ich es stimmt dass
wir sanktionen oder das teil das
aktionspaket es waren trotzdem ist
natürlich auch wichtig dass wir den
letzten schritt jetzt auch nicht
gegangen sind also ein gas embargo was
ja am anfang durchaus gefordert wurde
dass wir komplett aussteigen und so ganz
klar zeigen putin dass wir zu allem
bereit sind um dieser kriegs oder ein
kriegsszenario uns entgegen zu stellen
dazu haben wir natürlich auch nicht
durchgerungen das muss man vielleicht
auch bedenken und ich glaube zum bahnhof
und weise kennen sie sicher besser aber
es ging jetzt und düngemittel und das
ist jetzt auch nicht mein spezialgebiet
klar ist das düngemittel also ammoniak
ist so energie halte ich das der
grundstoff für viele düngemittel dass er
schon als statt wasserstoff zum beispiel
überlegt wird ihnen zu transportieren zu
verschiffen und so weiter weil es eben
eine grundchemikalien für viele weitere
prozesse ist daran merkt man ganz gut
also mit düngemitteln da reden wir im
grunde über tatsächlich und das ist ein
guter punkt von der schule über energie
abflüsse ja das ist fast so gut wie gas
oder öl zu exportieren so hoch ist der
energieanteil in düngemittel leben
also wenn man da schlupflöcher offen
lässt ich glaube dass man so in sri
lanka ist hatten wir gerade auch in der
tagesschau dort hat man ja die
düngemittel importe einbestellt
daraufhin sind die ernten auf die hälfte
zurückgegangen es war ein wichtiger teil
beim absturz dieses landes also das ist
ein extrem sensibles thema und wir
können ja ich sehr froh sein dass die
weizenpreise in den letzten monaten
wieder gesunken sind das zeigt nochmal
die erpressbarkeit ich kenne leider
jetzt tschuldigung man dann schaue ich
kenne leider jetzt die genaue situation
mit dem düngemittel nicht so bei also m
herr schule vielleicht das noch also der
vergleich sie haben ja gefragt warum
wurde das nicht aus den sanktionen
ausgenommen also richtig ist dass sie
genau also das gas fließt ja und jetzt
geht es eben um die gewarteten teile die
er jetzt auch gerade also die turbine
die nötig ist damit das gas wieder
möglicherweise zu 100 prozent fließen
kann die wird ja jetzt auch geliefert
ansonsten glaube ich aber haben sie
einen interessanten aspekt aufgemacht
wie man möglicherweise an verschiedenen
anderen stellen noch in dieser energie
krise helfen kann er schon eine vielen
dank auf jeden fall für eine frage und
einen schönen sonntag noch
ich würde gerne zu christiane kirche auf
jetzt gehen nach bonn hallo und ihre
frage bitte
monat lang
und nun alles geredet haben in russland
ein daten kaufen darf und das wurde
immer wieder will das diskutiert und
kann warten
ich bin also überhaupt
aber weiter
und
macht ja sie sich durchsetzen so jetzt
zeigt er uns zu sagen
ja genau und sie in ihre frage ist
letztendlich
meine frage ist man hätte vielleicht
nicht so viel reden wollen bevor man
über all diese sanktionen rede die sache
erstmal
weniger über die möglichkeit eines gas
boykotts reden ihre frage haben wir
damit ihnen nicht noch
gereizt das jetzt zu tun
herr reitz ich habe mich erinnert das
daran sie haben ich finde sie haben
recht und einen guten punkt
mich erinnert was daran wir haben mal
angefangen mich dem thema
technikfolgenabschätzung
das war eine idee die kam sollte er aus
dem grünen lager aus hall technik
skepsis und damit haben wir angefangen
die idee heute wäre zu überlegen braucht
man nicht eine folgenabschätzung eine
risikoabschätzung wenn man aussteigt aus
techniken und ich glaube da zählt die
dame genau drauf und das ist einfach
unterblieben wir haben uns darauf
verlassen dass putin das manchmal sogar
jahrzehnte gemacht hat nämlich selbst in
oder was russland über jahrzehnte die
sowjetunion selbst in politischen krisen
wurde geliefert nur der gasmarkt ist ja
zweigeteilt es gibt die langfristigen
verträge und es gibt den spot markt und
am spot markt haben die russen schon
seit über einem halben jahr eine schon
länger seit zehn zwölf monaten die
lieferungen reduziert und darauf ist
nicht reagiert worden deswegen hätte man
schon bei der frage der lagerstätten in
dem moment wo die russen sagen wir
füllen euch eure
gasspeichern nicht mehr in dem moment
hätte man schon reagieren
können insofern muss man sie haben
völlig recht ruhe nachdenken wenn du
irgendwo was machst hat es im nächsten
schritt an der anderen ecke konsequenzen
und wir brauchen eine risikoabschätzung
dessen was wir tun möchte ein ganz kurz
nur ergänzen putin ist ja nicht nur ein
schlimmer finger sondern es war
natürlich ein unglaublicher angriff auf
unsere gesagt welt orte und ja dort
vorgenommen hat bis hin zur nuklearen
drohung ich glaube deswegen haben anfang
entschlossen zu reagieren
schon wichtig und man muss natürlich
auch bedenken putin sitzt nur deswegen
anführungsstriche am längeren hebel weil
er bereit ist sein eigenes land zu
ruinieren es ist ja nicht so dass ich
das gerade alles für gerechnet und wenn
er uns das gas abdrehen würde sich das
auch nicht zwangsläufig hin drin rechnen
er kann es sich leider leisten in der
jetzigen situation aber nur weil er sein
land komplett unter seiner herrschaft
bezwungen hat wir müssen das ist jetzt
die zeit auch noch wieder hörerinnen und
hörer zu wort kommen lassen deshalb
möchte ich gerne zu kerstin staritz nach
bautzen gehen hallo und was möchten sie
von uns wissen
guttenberg
[Musik]
und wie wir alle mitgemacht haben die
privat kapitalmärkte eu liberalisiert
wurden also freier handel freie welt und
das die machen können was sie wollen und
wenn geld die welt regiert wie man so
schön dass wenn der planeten in bunbury
schlange gerettet worden also wir haben
noch gar keine handlung
bevollmächtigung mehr wenn die
kapitalmärkte spekulieren können auf
rohstoffe auf kriege auf staatsbankrotte
das hat doch mit unguten gar nicht mehr
zu tun daran wirklich nur auf gehangen
die chinesen sind ja noch viel schlimmer
wie die roten davon spricht keiner
israel und die sanktion gegen guten gar
nicht mit weil es wahrscheinlich selber
dadurch in bangkok gelten würde weil
alle miteinander verbunden und frau
stolz über ihre meiner bitte
die bei ökonomischen regeln sind
profitmaximierung und das gilt für alle
kapital mehr deswegen kann ich gar keine
wir haben wunderbare frau starre tragen
andere frage bitte an die runde
also dass wir jetzt sehr ernst er die
therapie begleiten welt regiert und das
hat mit guten gar nichts zu tun oder was
soll man tun um organisiert dass die
politik die verantwortung auf sich auch
die bilanz kapitalmärkte übergeben hat
und warum gar nicht mehr handlung ok
frau startet dann versuche ich meine
frage daraus abzuleiten also geld
regiert die welt und was können wir dann
jetzt in diesem zustand tun diese frage
nehme ich jetzt mal mit in die runde und
wer möchte da gerne darauf antworten
wenn man es ja angesprochen wo damit
bei den anderen punkt kann man sehr
lange und länger als die sendung
diskutieren was ich damit meinte ist
dass wir natürlich schon eine
völkerrechtlich zementierte weltordnung
haben in der zum beispiel einen
angriffskrieg gegen ein souveränes land
etwas ist was wir nicht zulassen möchten
und wo auch wir uns darauf verständigt
haben und glücklicherweise hat es
seitdem funktioniert dass die atomare
bedrohung keine ist die wir als
menschheit zu lassen wollen das meinte
ich damit und ich glaube das kann man
keinem team schon sehr deutlich
vorwerfen ganz unabhängig davon wie man
zu der zu den anderen bewertungen der
welt steht und was jetzt das thema
rohstoffe angeht würde ich schon auch
einwenden wollen dass ein großteil
unseres wohlstands den wir uns in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten aufgebaut haben
natürlich darauf beruht dass wir zugang
zu rohstoffen haben und dass wir uns
dann auch die rohstoffe gesucht haben
die besonders günstig sind also das ist
eine davon hat die gesellschaft als
ganzes profitiert und nicht nur die
wirtschaft oder die unternehmen das ist
im moment so in mode dass die dass die
unternehmen sind wie die bösen sind ich
meine wir alle haben davon profitiert
und die lehre muss sein sich weniger
abhängig von einem einzelnen lieferland
und von einem energieträger zu
ja ich habe ihnen okay das land kurz
aber ich glaube tatsächlich wir erleben
ja im augenblick eher ein rückschritt
eine die globalisierung
also diese völlig grenzenlosen märkte
die sich anscheinend und die regeln die
dazu gehören die sich ausbreiten und
faust breiten und ausbreiten das ist ja
eigentlich vergangenheit wir reden im
augenblick über was ganz anderes wir
reden über den zerfall der welt in
verschiedene handels blocke diskussion
wie wir uns unsere lieferketten gegen
china isolieren von russland ganz zu
schweigen
das subsistenz prinzip sozusagen aus
einer sicherheitspolitischen
machtpolitischem kalkül heraus wird
diskutiert und insofern sind die zeiten
in denen diese grenzenlosigkeit dieser
ausweitung des mendes ruhig neoliberalen
modells
uns sehr beschäftigt hat die sind
eigentlich vorbei wir sind gerade
eigentlich bei der rückgabe
frage ist wie weit sie geht ich würde
sagen sie sollte nicht zu weit gehen auf
jeden fall
wir nehmen jetzt gerne noch eine
anruferin rein und zwar heidi klar in
der nähe von bremen aus weyhe hallo und
ihre frage bitte
klaus weyer ich habe mal folgende frage
bis vor kurzem wurden gasheizung ja noch
von der kfw gefördert ich weiß nicht ob
das heute noch so ist und wer das in
anspruch genommen hat und vielleicht
heute noch ab zahlt wie soll er sich
dennoch leisten sich eine andere
heizquelle zu erschaffen
wärmepumpe was auch immer hinzu kommt
außerdem dass in vielen altbauten oder
gar nicht mal so alten bauten unterbau
ist von 1980 der einbau einer wärmepumpe
mit mit riesigen umbaumaßnahmen
verbunden wäre wie stellt man sich denn
darüber wie man
hausbesitzer dann davon überzeugt sich
da andere heilquellen zuzulegen danke
für diese frage frau hat genickt genau
ein großes thema genau der die die gerne
pumpe offensive von halberg also das ist
in der tat ein punkt
was die anrufer zu recht gesagt hat er
in älteren häusern sind wärmepumpen oft
nur dann zu real oder nur dann effizient
wenn man das haus komplett saniert was
gewaltige kosten mit sich zieht es gibt
sanierungs förderprogramme und die
bundesregierung will auch versuchen die
förderprogramme so auszurichten dass
stärker sanierungen und weniger
neubauten gefördert werden aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist ein gewaltiger
kostenblock der da auf die einzelnen
haushalte zu kommt sowohl in der
anschaffung und dann auch mit dem wagnis
wie ist es dann tatsächlich in betrieb
und das ist was worüber noch viel zu
reden sein wird wer das bezahlt und vor
allem auch der das macht aber auch die
preise für wärmepumpen sind in den
letzten monaten gestiegen die für
solarkollektoren sind gestiegen also
diese ganze energiewende im
gebäudebereich wird für die
immobilieneigentümer neuer das muss man
das alles die handwerker die fehlen um
die wärmepumpen einzubauen davon hatten
wir es ja schon ich glaube wir schaffen
noch ein anrufer und zwar eckard ritter
aus garbsen hallo und fragen sie uns
bitte
[Musik]
oder immer navi ohne wird noch mit
bürgern und david
nugent mal gemacht wir reden immer noch
bei der gaskrise aber wohl gegen der
noch eine ölheizung
damit ist die ölheizung noch einen
vorteil ganz klar im augenblick ein
riesenvorteil öl ist zwar auch im preis
gestiegen gerade in euro weil der euro
auch schwächelt um die 100 euro sind das
jetzt pro
fass öl das ist aber nichts im vergleich
zu den gas preissteigerungen also die
haushalts endkundenpreise wenn der
gaspreis da bleibt wo er jetzt ist an
den börsen dann kommt das eben auf ihrem
vertrag ankommt aber irgendwann über die
nebenkostenabrechnung oder über die
preiserhöhungen bei ihnen an und dann
reden wir von einer verzehnfachung und
bei öl reden wir vielleicht von einer
verdopplung das um mal so die
dimensionen deutlich zu machen ja im
augenblick haben sie mit einer ölheizung
richtig glück gehabt
klare klare frage klare antwort nur
verdoppelt
also das zeigt glaube ich auch noch mal
die dimensionen
des problems oder der herausforderung
auf die wir da zu gehen das hat auch der
austausch mit den gästen bei diesem
presseclub ergeben es war sicherlich
nicht die letzte sendung zum thema
energie versorgungssicherheit und
energiekrise wir haben vieles
aufgeworfen was wir dann in weiteren
sendungen noch mal besprechen werden
danke an meine gäste danke auch an sie
für ihr interesse und ich wünsche ihnen
noch einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]